[Musique]
voilà
on sent qu'ils ont
[Musique]
bonjour à tous bonjour maurice bonjour
lumière qu'est ce que tu nous propose
aujourd'hui maurice et bien tout cas
aujourd'hui j'ai l'intention de faire
des boissons pour accompagner tous ces
petits plats alors je vais je te propose
un frappé à la banane et un super si
dans tous à vos stylos
il est est une autre fois le frapper à
la banane et le spécial si dans le
frapper à la banane quatre bananes un
litre de lait 2 cuillerées de sucre en
poudre
une pointe de cannelle une pointe de
gingembre 12 cubes de glace le spécial 6
dont 6 orange de pamplemousse de verre
de sirop de grenadine une demi bouteille
de limonade et 12 cubes de glace alors
nous allons commencer par le frapper à
la banane doit alors tu prends tes
bonnes études aux étrangers est une les
arrose pas d'un jus de citron ou bleu
marine d'ana
donnons-nous aujourd'hui on va mettre du
lait d'ailleurs tout comme le passé très
bien quand tu vois mon père c'est parti
oui très bien c'est bien tu me passes le
sucre également ancien mari mais là le
sucre je vais mesurer voix et il va me
passer la cannelle et le gingembre
je vais leur mettre une points mais on
peut peut-être expliquer ce que ce sont
la cannelle gingembre morris ou ford à
la cannelle et un aromate qu'on obtient
par raclage décor du canonnier
lecavalier ça ressemble un peu l'oreille
et yvan quand gingembre c'est un
condiment qui nous vient d'où dany
mauritanie ce j'ai appris beaucoup de
choses avec toi bon maintenant je suis
calé alors tu vas tu l'as bien écraser
tu l'as bien mélanger et humer de la
guerre parce que c'est ce bois rue des
cubes de glace parce que ça se boit gacé
alors nous allons goûter tout à l'heure
maintenant nous allons faire le super
six
oui tu as donc écrasé des oranges quand
tu mets deux tiers de jus d'orange
pour un tiers que juste un peu mou c'est
logiquement que mouss maurice rose ou
bien non mais tu peux non qu'elle n'a
pas d'importance japon voilà tu es
maintenant de la grenadine peut être
remplacé par du sirop de menthe à nous
ils rasent aujourd'hui j'ai retiré
coller ou à tout à l'heure je t'aiderai
pourquoi tu mets de la limonade du
convoi si on n'a pas des limonades est
quand même meilleur jour avec la bouche
suit le scouser 28 cents tu vois
pourquoi si on me demande qu'est-ce que
ça ressemble ça tu as raison mon service
m'a dit ah ouais alors si tu veux on va
déguster
chacun apprend juste un petit bonjour
d'huy et qui me paraît triste
aujourd'hui je suis content et on va se
quitter maurice ont jeté voler ton
torchon tu vas être un peu ça oui oui
bon c'est que je vais prendre le
croisement tablier de faire une visite
au kenya au revoir à tous
mais peut-être après très bientôt
envoyons protéines sans charbon naturel
parfumé sens et
sans danger ciboulette son robot s'en
voulait sans doute notre quotidien sont
au coffre sans pépin ce sens me choque
cette saison j'ai redoublé en peloton
sans cuisson on rit de la cense à
l'accès fna lit pas les pires sans mélo
sans bobos sans alcool sans rsa 3par
inserv hong hao vitamines sans bobos
sans plus même temps brûlé 120% cuisson
[Musique]